ajakas is one of the most traditional
dish from caracas ajakas is a main thing
in venezuela every single christmas i'm
jorge rincombe i'm a chef i'm here to
make ajakas this recipe is a traditional
ayakas from caracas every single
december every family in venezuela tried
to make ajakas there's no better ajakas
they're just different ajakas i found
out also kurosawa they do ajakas in the
same way that we do in venezuela
close to the border of venezuela in
colombia they do something called
tamales which is really close to ajakas
but a jacket is from venezuela they are
different every single region in
venezuela have a different kind of a
jackass in caracas especially they are
sweet
and a little bit spicy you have to
prepare this too in advance because it
is a process that you have to try to
make one date before
and everyone in the family is involved
to make a jackass people start trading
ajakas with other families and everyone
has a part of the assembly line of the
ajakas they make 200 300 because
everyone wants to show to others how the
jackass are is like a big party for
every single family and there is not
christmas without ajakas ajakas is a
main thing in venezuela every single
christmas
is an old tradition and it's past
four generations
you have to start with the toe of the
day before also
the dough have to be really really
flavored you have to feel that in this
dog you put a lot of effort
you have to check that the lift has no
vein if you dunk out the vein the vein
is just gonna makes you difficult to
fold it the lift they have to be cooked
once you finish and you see that color
is changed and the flexibility is much
better you have your leaf ready
the lift comes from africa we have the
core from our traditional indians
and the european influence are mostly in
the stew all together makes something
big for venezuelan tradition that is
unique
the gardener mixed with a little dijon
mustard something that you never expect
there but it's another explosion in your
mouth
with these flavors
then whilst you close the ajakas fold it
just like a present because in the end
ajakas are just like a present
especially on christmas we wrap it just
like a present give it away just like a
present
[Music]
christmas music like guy does then you
start making a jackass with your family
is a whole process that protects you all
day but is happiness is family together
brings you so many memories because
every single december every family in
venezuela try to make ajakas
i hope people like this way to make a
jackass because this tradition means a
lot to millions of people in venezuela
colombia and curacao oh yes
[Music]
is
[Music]